psychologically what do those things do
to you
do you have ever you have flashbacks you
have middle of the night you wake up
with nightmares does it do anything like
that to you because you know many people
in your world tell me stories like that
but i wonder what it does to you
i think it makes you more look
i love life you know
it's what we're here for isn't it and i
love my grandchildren and i love
everything you know that's wraps around
me but you become a bit of a fatalist
you understand that it's what was ansi
hopkins who said you know none of us get
out of here alive
but it's the choices that you've made or
the choices that somebody else has made
for you and do i do i have dark moments
yeah i suppose i do but i'm not i don't
hang on them i remember i remember every
postmortem that i ever went to i
remember standing next to a lady who had
taken her own life on christmas eve
in a mortuary
and there was no viewing gallery and the
the pathologist is undertaking a
postmortem on her body
they stick with my in my mind telling
her family
that we've found the body of them their
mother you know they are the things that
stick with me forever but that's not
going to dent me as an individual
because
it's like saying i want i wanted to join
i want to go on a murder squad but i
don't want to see a dead body that just
doesn't work does it it's like saying
yeah i want to be a traffic cop but i
never want to go to a row collision no
come on do me a favor it's not going to
it's not going to happen so you've got
to be very pragmatic about it in your
approach
um but you do say look i saw a guy my
first experience of i'd experienced
deaths before but the first guy
um that i've seen as a horrific
death um he'd been decapitated in a row
collision he was in the road he knelt up
and as he knelt up off the road he had a
few drinks taxi came along and
took him off took his head off here and
that was that was horrendous and i'd
seen people that jumped in front of
trains and then at five o'clock in the
morning as the sun starts to come up in
you know in june july time
the sun comes up and the birds are there
picking up these poor chaps body bits
you know that have been sprayed across
the place
they stay with you does that affect me
yeah those times i've been in tears
i remember i was a family people think
that
i don't know the american culture i've
got family in america and um i love
absolutely love the states but it's like
comparing apples with pears and they're
going to think i'm a softbugger you know
that's that's the
but i i was a family liaison officer for
a young lady and she'd been struck by a
train and it took two weeks to find her
body
and i remember getting on a plane with
my family going into spain flying down
to spain and
everybody's reading the national
newspapers and there she was on the
front page of national newspapers and we
we'd announced that we'd found her body
yeah they'd been all over the national
media the bbc itv the whole thing and i
just let them cry because you think
that kid's been in that
she's been dead for two weeks and we've
only just found her body so yes it does
affect you you dealt i dealt with some
lovely people from the victims
perspective
um i dealt with some really interesting
people
i dealt with some very interesting
suspects because they've all got a story
to tell so if you like this sort of
short club from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]